after Sunday night's horrific shooting  at a music festival in Las Vegas many  celebrities are reacting with messages  of prayers but also with calls for more  gun control in the u.s. ariana grande  whose concert in the UK was bombed  earlier this year  killing 23 people and injuring hundreds  tweeted Monday we need love unity peace  gun control and for people to look at  this and call it what it is terrorism  more messages from supermodel Gigi Hadid  actress January Jones shameless star  Emmy Rossum comedian Billy Eichner and  actress Julianne Moore all posting on  social media calling for better gun  control and lady gaga tweeted at Speaker  of the House Paul Ryan and President  Donald Trump writing prayers are  important but blood is on the hands of  those who have power to legislate gun  control act quickly as of Monday morning  more than 50 people had been killed in  Las Vegas and hundreds injured  [Music]  you